today we're talking about vms cyber
security and our partners i'm debbie and
welcome to this week in cloud where we
serve you the lowest latency news
one of the best aspects of the cloud is
the ability to purchase and use only
what you need this enables you to take
advantage of modern and performant
computing while fine-tuning cost
optimization with suspend resume now
generally available you have even more
control over your google cloud resource
consumption you can think of it like
closing your laptop head to the blog for
more details
as we continue our series on healthcare
and cybersecurity we'll focus next on
establishing sustainable visibility
mechanisms so cyber security teams
working in our global health care system
can secure and preserve patient care and
safety check out the blog for further
details and more about how healthcare
can strengthen its cybersecurity
resilience
our tech and startup customers are
disrupting industries driving innovation
and changing how people do things we're
proud of their success and want to
showcase what they're up to
you'll hear about their new products
their businesses reaching new milestones
and their ability to get things done
faster and easier using google cloud's
app development data analytics and aiml
services a full list is up on the blog
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud
you